[Music]  darling come on over welcome to your  party this is an event for you a theme  that is so entrained and who you are  what does it mean to be here tonight  that means I get to be with my favorite  designer and favorite friend from France  Jean Paul Gautier that's about the look  well my dress is basically across yes  and we we're both Catholic and we have  very very active imagination  [Applause]  Madonna shutting down the Met Gala red  carpet any chance you'll get up and  perform tonight  right now I'm performing before heading  inside for an epic performance  [Music]  you like to have use this imagery and  your music in your career for so long  and to finally be here at the Met stairs  with your favorite designer  I think they waited too long it's about  time we thought punk was your year but  this is it yeah this is my year  [Music]  [Applause]